hey it's Jesse
and today I've been doing a lot of
research on how to do file uploads with
with node so I'm gonna fill you in on
what I've what I've learned what I'm
thinking about doing and maybe you'll
have some better ideas so on the screen
now you can see I've successfully set up
a let me take this out really quick
because I just added that in there I
haven't really done anything with it yet
but so I've successfully set up the
server j/s file so yesterday I was
talking about that and had I think it
was Kevin that had mentioned like just
put a server J's file in there and it
will work and it that's it that's
exactly what happened it works so I put
this in here and I this is like straight
from the documentation on github for
create react app so really simple and
they worked I started it up and
basically so it took I did have to build
so I ran yarn build created this build
folder and now it's just serving
everything from that build folder so
really cool everything works so this is
then where we're gonna handle our
uploads in our server dot JS file so I
was thinking about using this package
Moltar because I've used it before with
react
to do file uploads so I thought why not
why not try it again but maybe there's
something newer and better out there
that I don't know about so let me know
if any of you have experience with that
otherwise I think I'm gonna go ahead
with this since I have some experience
with it I do it one question alive said
I'll just answer it right now so I don't
forget since it's the first one there
do so and ask this did he already set up
some JWT so JSON web token off with
Express JWT it said no I haven't set
that up yet although I probably won't
need to for this project yeah I don't
think I'll need to there's another
project that I did that I really really
want to redo in react and I might need
it for that so I'm gonna keep that in
mind for the future
let's see Oh pool request I've got some
really exciting news from the pool
requests so check this out let me
look at this it's the SAS file so this
is SCSS syntax so Patrick submitted a
pull request where he set everything up
so that we can now use SAS on this
project so if you clone this repo you
can use SAS too
yeah I'm super excited about it so yes I
haven't actually written any SAS yet but
I'm excited to be able to do it I can
have variables and all the other awesome
stuff and be able to nest things so
really cool I honestly didn't realize
how much I missed SAS until I had it
back again and now I'm like I'm so happy
because I haven't used it for well for
this project or for the last project and
that our last project was I mean what
that was at least a month of working on
that I think so yeah and then actually
what I was working on before that was
like an existing project that I had to
work within the constraints of that
project and it didn't have SAS so it's
been it's been months since I've been
able to use as so if you're not familiar
with SAS it's a CSS preprocessor so it
allows you to do some stuff with CSS
that you can't normally do and then when
you're ready you have you have it set up
so that it converts all of that s CSS or
SAS into CSS that browsers can can read
so that's what I'm talking about here so
it just makes it really nice and as the
project continues and we actually write
some things in SAS hopefully you'll get
to see like some of the advantages of
using it and it's it's just so some
things are just so much faster to write
if if you're using SAS so hopefully
we'll get a chance to show sure the
advantages had some other pull requests
as well
I just want to make sure everyone's
caught up with with where the project is
so let me let me double check yeah so we
had two other pull requests so the the
SAS one was from Patrick and then Kevin
submitted two one was actually it OTO
calculates the pixel Heights so if you
remember yesterday the last thing that
we did in this tutorial was we were
vertically aligning it but it was off
and it was causing the scrollbar as well
because we had set this section at first
we had just said it to be this container
div that basically is here goes from
here to here we had set it to be a
hundred percent of the viewport height
well then we obviously had three things
off and it made us have a scrollbar so
we needed to deduct the height of this
this NAB at the top well I just
hard-coded like 64 pixels because that
was pretty much the height it was its
axis like a fraction of a pixel smaller
than that well Kevin I think even said
it during the live stream was like you
know which maybe you should Auto
calculate that so he went ahead and did
it himself so now this gets calculated
so even if we end up making this bigger
or smaller
it doesn't matter it'll always look good
so that's really cool so I mean you
could check out the code for that I'm
not gonna go through any of the pull
request code like line by line because I
think what we're gonna attempt to do
today is a pretty involved project so I
want to save as much time as I can for
that so that's really cool also he added
some more testing and if you check out
the closed pull requests in this this
repo and the link to the repos in the
description you'll see so in the latest
pull request for
and to end testing says for requests 23
Kevin had a really nice description of
the different types of testing so the
one that we've been doing and then it so
other types so check that out if you're
if you're new to testing you're not
really sure what's going on there it was
a really really good description and I
got a lot out of it so thanks for that
and then not only that but Patrick also
explained his pull request from
yesterday if you member yesterday I went
through and I showed what he had done
and for some of the parts I said I
honestly don't know a hundred percent
what's going on here but I know it works
because I tested it so Patrick went
through and provided an explanation you
know pretty much line by line of
everything that that he had done so if
you like me we're slightly lost by that
that code then check out that that
description and that was on pull request
let me let me see I have it on the
others my other screen here nineteen so
pull request nineteen and pull request
twenty to have some really good really
good comments get information on there
so thanks thanks again Kevin and Patrick
not only for the pull request but then
for taking the time to explain things to
me so thoroughly I really appreciate
that okay so let's go to our service
request forms this is where we have our
file upload this is where we're gonna be
focusing on not really anything with the
the visuals with the UI or anything like
that we're basically just we're gonna be
setting up this server j/s file so as
you can see I brought in so right now
like this works I can turn the server on
I could go to localhost 9000 and the
site it works it looks good just the
same as it does you know through an grok
oh I forgot to turn in grog on let me do
that right now
and actually fill for right now I'm
going to turn on the port 3000 version
of this but if we start with the file
upload stuff later on and we start
running things through port 9000 honours
from our server JS file maybe I'll
switch and I'll run that through in grok
we'll just see how it goes
all right salute yet
here's a URL and I'm gonna put that in
the live chat oh and there's a lot going
on the latch at let me take a look
Adrian asked to use meteor with reacts I
have not used meteor with reacts is that
a thing didn't do people normally use
meteor with reacts I'm not I'm not
really sure
I've seen some demonstrations of stuff
built with using meteor and it looked
really cool and like super fast so I'm
definitely interested in meteor
I just don't know a whole lot about it
mohamad asks what's the what's the
difference between sass and scss the
syntax slightly different with sass it's
based on indentation so you don't have
like your curly braces and things like
that and I see John Hanson had answered
as well I just thought it might be a
good question to repeat out so yeah
mainly that's that's pretty much the
difference just a little bit different
syntax but they can do the same I think
all the same things the benefit though
to using SCSS is that you could copy and
paste normal CSS into an S CSS file and
it'll still work if you tried to do that
in copy and paste normal CSS into a sass
file it would not work so that's why I
use s CSS instead of sass if that's
that's really the only reason otherwise
I think it's actually faster to write
sass than s CSS
okay I was just double-checking and
seeing what's going on in the live chat
okay cool so I had some answers about
meteor so evidently Adrien is learning
meteor and react together so that's
awesome Patrick says I think meteor is
moving away from defaulting to blaze and
is defaulting to react okay that's
really cool I'm gonna have to read up
more on that because it's been probably
over a year since I read or saw anything
about meteor so I need to need to catch
up okay Kevin says the downside to using
the custom servers that I'll lose the
hot reloading yeah I don't like that
you're basically what I'm thinking is so
let me let me fill everybody in on
what's gonna happen so like right now I
have this running on port 3000 localhost
and this is through the the create react
app server so it comes with cool stuff
like like hot hot reloading and like
everything else is hooked into that that
start command so now like our our sass
compiling and stuff so that's really
good and I don't want to lose that what
will happen though if we run let me see
oh I don't have it running anymore okay
so I was going to show you the screen
where I have the other server running
but I turned it off so when we start
running this like we lose all that so
what I'm thinking about doing is getting
the file upload and the form stuff to
work making sure it works with this and
then doing the rest of the development
like we normally did and basically just
kind of ignoring this until we're ready
ready to move this into production
I don't know maybe there's a better way
to do that but I mean I I don't really
need the follow-up loads to work all the
time I just need them to work once so I
can test it and once I'm satisfied that
that works then I'm I don't really care
about it
okay and there's someone in the chat and
I can't I'm not sure what their name is
because it's not in normal characters
that I'm used to but they're asking
about like getting started and coding
and things so I just want to acknowledge
that I I see you're asking you're
getting some feedback there in the live
chat so yeah like stick around watch
what we're doing and you know ask
questions if I would say free code camp
is a really good place to start if
you're just beginning
looks like you've studied Python so
maybe like you're a little bit more
advanced than that so you probably fly
through all the beginner free code camp
stuff and probably won't slow down until
you get to the more advanced JavaScript
things because you know if you know
Python the concepts will be the same
they're just just the syntax you'll have
to get used to so all right so I'm gonna
get started I'll do one more question
since it just popped up and just Andrew
asked if I've used redux for any of my
projects not yet but I will be probably
in the future because I'm gonna take a
course I'm taking a course right now
Udacity nanodegree I finished the first
I think that I think they call each part
a course so I guess I finished the first
course the second course starts in like
a week and I'll go over Redux in that
course so after I finished with that I
will know at least the basics of Redux
and I can start incorporating it into my
projects okay cool also as as you all
probably know we have a secondary stream
going on on Instagram the links in the
description for that so if you if you
happen to join in on Instagram if you're
watching on Instagram and you don't know
what's going on I'm coding I'm building
stuff and react so tune in to free code
camp YouTube
to see the code alright so let me pull
over so I I have up on my other screen
screen just to shake way too many tabs
of tutorials for how to do this okay so
this is what I happen to be working
looking at right now so multiple file
upload with nodejs which is exactly what
we want right here so I've been checking
out different tutorials I haven't seen
one that's like perfect one looked
really good but they it was in
typescript and I thought I don't know
anything about site script so I'm just
gonna try to find a different tutorial
so maybe type strips not that different
and like I could have figured it out but
I figured there's got to be a lot of
tutorials on this so you just move on so
like this one is using Ajax which we're
not going to use Ajax obviously but it
seems like the common thread between a
lot of these tutorials is that they are
all using Moltar and some of them are
using body parser I don't know if we'll
need this or not I did use this in my
last project but looking at the
documentation for Moltar it didn't say
that you needed this so I'm maybe this
used to be needed and now you don't need
it anymore not really sure
it looks like yeah this looks like this
is not gonna be a lot of code this one
seems to be the most straightforward of
the tutorials there's not a lot of extra
stuff in there that that will be
confusing that we we won't need so I'm
gonna copy a lot of this I you know what
I do want to know about body parts or
let me go back to the MultiAir
documentation if anybody knows anything
about this please you know let me know
in the in the live chat definitely open
to your suggestions also let me get my
Pomodoro timer going if if you're not
familiar with the timer so this is a way
to kind of organize your workday and
track things so I use this normally but
for the streams I use this to remind me
to stop coding and talking and instead
check the live chat so I don't miss too
much so yeah let's just I'm probably
gonna end up copy and pasting this and
just testing and see see how it is I
also have somewhere in here in one of
these tabs the older project that I had
done where I did something similar so I
can refer to that as well if I need to
because I I know it works and I've done
it
I just need I'll probably pull led to my
other strings I need to make sure I
don't have anything since it's a private
repo I didn't bother like hiding any of
the keys or anything so I don't to make
sure I don't have anything in that file
that I shouldn't show everyone on
YouTube so I might I might not show that
I might just copy and paste some stuff
out of there
and then bring it over but it looks like
it's really similar to the tutorial
okay here's the multi documentation so
let me bring this over to show you so
this is this is a package that we're
using actually let me before I forget
I'm gonna make this bigger cuz I had a
comment on one of the videos sometime
within the last day of somebody saying
that I need to make it make this stuff
bigger so I apologize when I'm not
streaming I make it smaller so that I
could see more of the code and I
probably had forgotten to make it bigger
so sorry about that this this ought to
be big enough I think this seems seems
pretty big let me know if it's not okay
and then I'll also make this a bit
bigger as well probably too big alright
so for this like I said they're not
using the the body parser at all
so I'm not sure I think I may end up
just using it because that's how I did
it the last time that's how this
tutorial does it so it'll probably end
up going more smoothly if I use what's
the you know exactly what they're using
so hey we got somebody in oh cool so
it's a new day is is also in the
Instagram stream and sorry if I'm
mispronouncing that I think it's day but
I just want to bring that up because I
hope he doesn't mind me saying this but
today is ooh today's birthday so happy
birthday and that's it's really awesome
that you're watching my stream on your
birthday you can be doing whatever you
want I guess on your birthday so anyway
thanks thanks for watching hopefully
this will be a good stream and we can do
some accomplish some cool stuff here
okay cool I got some in the live chat
got some info about the bawdy parser
package so kevin says bawdy parser
parses query parameters passed through
the URL and form encoded data or json
and the body of the post request I don't
think you actually need it okay cool
ajaan okay John recommends looking at
node formidable that's worth worth
checking out since we haven't really
done anything yet this is the time to
explore alternatives so let's check this
out okay
always I just like to look when I see
initially like how many stars does does
it have
and once the last time was updated okay
so within the last year it's been
updated you have four months okay
whereas motor was did we have it on the
screen still I guess not I guess I
pulled it over to the side I'm just
comparing okay so in terms of stars
they're about the same formidable is a
little bit more and it actually looks
like formidable is more up-to-date so
this looks cool it's definitely worth
looking at that's it for me especially
follow yeah this looks like
cool I like it so far
Wow okay it looks like this may already
be integrated into Express
well it looks like there's a lot more to
this documentation as well which I guess
is is a good thing see the the moon surd
documentation is is pretty short oh I
guess there's more to it than I
initially thought now that I look at it
I guess I just didn't scroll down enough
all right what do y'all think I'm kind
of split here I'm gonna I'm open to
suggestions
to see if you all have any opinion
should we try to do this with multi or
should we try to do it with formidable
I really have no idea which one is the
more widely used of the two
and I'm gonna pull a pull the
documentation over and then that way we
can have all the code on the screen
kevin said maybe branch off and throw a
coin yeah so I'm actually working just
so you know if you want to check out the
repo I don't think I've pushed any of
this new code up yet this is a new
branch wow that's really small this is a
new branch and I named a custom server
so everything we do now will be in terms
of this will be on the new branch so we
don't mess anything up and if we get it
to the point where we're confident that
it's working and not messing anything up
then of course we'll merge it back in
but so for now I don't think it's it's
actually available but I will before I
leave today I'll make sure I'll push
whatever we're we did up to to get home
and that way you co can see it
all right so I'm trying to see if I have
a coin in here I mean oh yeah actually I
do
I have a coin in my backpack so I am
actually going to throw a coin so you
can you can't see this but you could if
you're on the Instagram feed you'll see
it so what do you say heads will be
formidable and then tails will be multi
all right so I'm flipping it now it's
heads all right so we're gonna go with
formidable
okay now Joseph put in the live chat
that Google has you can do Google a coin
flip so we didn't what am I thinking
flipping a real coin you know there's
got to be a virtual way to do it that's
better
all right but anyway flip the coin its
formidable so this is like real serious
coding here right we're making making
big decisions by flipping coins
all right cool so let's then remove I
think I had already added yeah I added
this package I'm gonna remove it and
then let's maybe we have to add
formidable so I don't know if you caught
it at the beginning of the documentation
but it seemed like it was saying that
it's already included in express so I
guess we can find out by just trying to
use it and seeing if it works
so I'm going to do that let's go to our
code let's get rid of this and I'm I
guess I'm just gonna try to paste in
some of the just really basic example
code and they're using their instead of
constant the sample code what the heck
in case you don't know what I'm talking
about by that it's the es6 you can use
constant let instead of their to declare
your your variables so if if you can if
you're if you're using a transpiler then
definitely use a Const or let alright so
I'm just trying to see what I need to
copy and what I don't need to copy
[Music]
and I just I don't like how they
formatted this oh well we'll copy it
over I can always change the formatting
so definitely want this to be Const and
I don't like this
okay
now that looks better
okay so they're doing yeah this is a bit
confusing the sorry I'm talking about
their example so in formidable github
page it's slightly confusing because you
know they have it's not set up exactly
right so like there's no Express here
and things like that so I need an
example that uses Express I mean if if
there is one that would be nice I guess
we can figure it out without that but
just want to want to try that out let's
see
I thought there was a link to something
about using it with express there we go
okay cool Joseph just said there's
there's an express formidable awesome
okay so here is Express formidable
although it's let's see how this works I
mean there's like 30 stars so let's
let's see what's going on here maybe we
will use this or at least we can get
some idea of how to use formidable
I mean that that looks really really
simple
okay so you have some questions so
formidable sis's marks asking a question
about formidable it's going to help us
upload files and store them so we have a
file upload input and that we need to do
something with the files once we get
them okay john hanson
recommended looking in the sorry looking
at something else on my screen he
recommended looking in the examples
folder in that repo and I did not
so definitely should do that so let me
I'm checking it right now my other
screen
okay
it's still looking
yeah it's still looking pretty much the
same as what was on the homepage in
terms of like not having expression both
actually it looks like there's a lot of
information on using formidable with
express it's just I just did a Google
search on my other screen and a lot of
people trying to do the same thing which
is good
all right so there is a tutorial so
let's check this out I think this was
from 2015 so hopefully it's not too
outdated but at least this shows this is
what I wanted to say something that's
starting with Express and then also
bringing in formidable
okay yeah this looks like definitely
looks like something I can use so I'm
gonna copy this as a start just to give
us something to work with
and there we have formidable I guess I
don't need these
okay so basically
okay so this handles uploads we do need
to make sure that we can handle the rest
of the form as well so I'm assuming that
formidable does that I mean it would
make sense that it would do that
okay yeah I can handle form data
okay this is a good place to start I
kind of just like really want to test
something first before I start
second-guessing things and copying other
things and so first thing I want to try
to do is just see as I was saying before
the do I really need to have formidable
like the documentation seem to was
seemed to say it already came with
Express which I'm not really sure that
it'll work like that but we'll see so
I'm just gonna start I'm just gonna try
to start the server let me think what
did I use before I came here what I used
before
their note sir well I couldn't I
remember that it's the same every time
you use it anyway okay cool
so that was easy enough we do need a to
add it which makes sense
so
okay
what's yarn add formidable
okay so we're now getting that package
and installing it and all the
dependencies okay cool
I saw it John I saw your comment there
about formidable does pull in all the
form data also Andrew I see Andrew asked
how I like the react nanodegree yeah I
am I like it so far
like I said I'm through there's
basically there's an introduction and
there's three courses or three sections
to the nanodegree and I'm through the
first one I like the first one the the
biggest benefit that I've seen so far
from that program has been being able to
submit projects and then get feedback
pretty quickly like within 24 hours and
for me it was it was always way less
than 24 hours and that that was really
challenging and good so hey I guess
somebody in the Instagram that's been
saying hi hey welcome yeah that was
really challenging because that's not
something that I normally have like
trying to teach myself something usually
is just me reading through things and
trying out out on my own without any
feedback from a real person so that was
good my my project ended up I had to
revise it a lot more than I thought I
would you know the first time I turned
it in I thought hey this thing works
it's done and it wasn't there was like
rounds of I don't remember how many but
like maybe like five I don't know it was
crazy how many times I turned in the
same project thinking that I had it
completely done and not realizing that
there was some little bug or some piece
you know one of the user stories that I
just was not completing so that was
really challenging and it forced me to
learn more and to you like refactor
a lot of what I had done so that that
was cool I really I did like that now I
can see the value and paying for those
courses that really the value is in real
people putting in work going over your
code line by line making comments
challenging you you know that's that was
the best part of it so anyway sorry for
the little sidebar there I am my
intention was to address that question
while this was loading but it's it
obviously loaded way faster then I
thought oh now we have this and now
let's just let's try to start this
server okay cool this is this is good it
doesn't it doesn't say anything right
now when I started so this this means
it's probably running and we can check
this by going to localhost 9000 awesome
it's working okay now we didn't actually
do anything to link up this forum so we
can't test this yet but at least it
shows that like one we have formidable
now and also like we don't have any
crazy errors in our server ojs file so
good step my timer went off so I'm gonna
take five minutes try to go through the
everything that's in the live chat so
far answer any questions and hopefully
hopefully I think I may be able to get
through most of us in the live chat
there's not a whole lot and I kept up
with it so after the five minutes is up
we'll go back and let's link up that
upload and see what happens when we we
actually try to upload something
what all right so Patrick says
extracting 306 million cracked passwords
from a 5.4 gig 5.4 gigabyte seven zip
file is really taking a long time what
are you doing why well how did this all
come about
okay we did have a question how can
JavaScript help you for working how does
it help you as a programmer pretty much
anything on the web now runs at least
some JavaScript so if you're into web
development at all then you probably
going to end up using javascript
especially since like the web has moved
away from alternatives so flash is not
really a thing anymore like Java applets
they don't you don't see those you know
anymore so everything is pretty much
JavaScript so it can definitely help you
with web development you can use
javascript in other areas as well
although you don't have to so you can do
JavaScript on the back end you can you
can build apps with JavaScript you can
even do BR stuff with JavaScript so now
you don't like I said you don't need
JavaScript for that but if you knew
JavaScript you could do all of that with
just JavaScript so I think there's value
in its versatility right now
the Moose says the atom editor what does
its hackable mean I'm new to coding
basically it just means that pretty much
everything in the editor you can
customize so you can actually go into
the code and customize what you want
it's I think Adam Adams an electron
bright I'm pretty sure so if you go into
the code for Adam it'll look really
familiar because it'll they'll be like
CSS that you can edit and things so a
lot of I mean probably your basic place
to start with that would be editing CSS
to change colors but you know you could
get deeper into it people make a lot of
plugins to make Adam do a lot of
different things so that's that's what
they mean by hackable it just means
customizable
okay I see Patrick said there there's a
he looked up but and npn compared calm
and compared a bunch of the form
packages that are used with express in
note and said that formidable wins by a
lot so awesome
so our coin flip picked the right one
okay patchy should surprise grepping a
12.7 gigabyte file with 306 million
passwords to make sure your passwords
aren't in it is very slow okay now I
know what you were doing that okay that
makes a lot more sense so that's
actually really cool so let let's talk
about this for a second so you so you
have a file with all these crack
passwords and you're checking for your
passwords where did you get the file
varun says hi Jesse greetings from India
hey how's it going thanks for for
watching for joining us Jacobi says hey
what's up folks
just just building stuff with react
how's it going thanks for watching okay
Kevin said the express formidable
package is really just a thin wrapper
over formidable so that it works as a
middleware it's literally 23 lines of
code
okay cool so probably not really a big
deal to go with that then not it's not
gonna really add a lot and it might help
us out so I'm gonna I'll check that
again in a minute
okay Rohan asks if I visit if I did
visit the doctor and how my my hand is
so-so lately my right wrist has been
hurting a lot and so I actually did go
to the doctor two days ago so yeah so
after work two days ago I went basically
I have a wrist splint like a brace thing
that I wear I actually I can't wear it
when I'm working I tried to but like
when I try to type on the keyboard part
of the brace like hits keys that I don't
intend to hit so it's just and it's
sometimes it even ends up hurting worse
so I basically only wear the brace when
I don't need to work and then I just
like keep trying to put ice on it they
gave me like a pack of like steroid
pills that are supposed to take the the
inflammation down and other than that I
just need to try not to use it which is
hard because I'm right-handed so I'm
constantly trying to do things with my
right hand and I have to stop myself so
I'm starting to get used to it now
driving with my left hand was a little
weird and actually brushing my teeth
left-handed really weird eating
left-handed there's a lot of things that
you don't I just never thought about
doing with my my offhand and now they're
they're really weird so anyway that's
the update on my my wrist so it is
slightly better than it was yesterday so
I have been making more of an effort to
to not use it and actually the ice using
ice with it helps a lot so it feels
really good after I sit
okay I'm Patrick this would be the last
thing before I go back to the code here
since my time is up but in answer to my
questions about the password thing
Patrick says I have been poned dot-com
slash passwords awesome
cool yeah I am I've been on that lift
site before I guess I just didn't look
around enough I didn't realize you could
actually get lists of passwords but
that's really cool I'm definitely I'm
gonna have to go on there I'm typing it
in on my other screen just so I don't
forget because I need to be extra
careful I think with passwords
dang it I can't I have a VIN phone did I
type it wrong but anyway I need to I
feel like I need to be extra careful
because I have access to so many
people's websites that I like have an
obligation to be more careful than than
normal with passwords so I don't know
how it is with you all but if specially
if you've done any freelancing do you
all have access to like a ton of
websites because that's how it is with
me and it makes me nervous sometimes
especially if my kids want to play
something on my computer that I I'm like
no you can't you could accidentally like
break somebody's website yeah so anyway
I mean how do you handle that like I'm
still I'm still an admin for so many
WordPress installations though for a lot
of businesses and though they probably
never ever login to their WordPress
thing so it's never changed
they've never like I had I bet you
probably 90% of my clients even from
like four or five years ago I could
probably log into their site right now
because they never think to change the
password and I would still have admin
access I'm pretty sure I still have FTP
access to people's sites and they don't
even realize it yeah so I mean that's
probably a bad thing but otherwise it's
sometimes you get clients like I could
give them everything they need to access
it through FTP and they'd never even
know how to do it or want to do it so
it's not like you can hand over that
information because there's there's no
one there that can understand that and
use it so anyway sorry for the tangent
but it's a little ethical dilemma of
like [ __ ] should I just lock myself out
of everything and then those clients
would probably then be locked out
because they really probably shouldn't
be admins on it either sometimes their
passwords are like really really simple
so definitely should not have admin
access so it's it's a bit of a dilemma I
don't know let me know what you think
about that like it does make me a little
nervous I mean it doesn't keep me up at
night but I am a bit nervous
that I have I have so much access to so
many sites but I don't really I don't
really know a good solution to that okay
so anyway in case you had no idea what
we were talking about this is the site I
have been phoned com put in your email
address or username and then it should
tell you if anything is any accounts
associated with that email or username
if those sites have suffered like a data
breach and then potentially your
password has been exposed and if you use
that same password on other accounts
then potentially your other accounts
could be exposed as well so really
useful I'm not gonna search for mine in
front of all of you because maybe I am
maybe my stuff has been exposed and
before I'd have a chance to change it
somebody might I don't think one of you
would try to get into my stuff but it's
possible okay so let's go back to here
and let's just see what are we doing
okay so what we need to do is post two
uploads from our request form
so right now I don't really care about
the rest of the forum right now I want
to test out the file upload first
because the rest normal uploads are a
lot more simple it's been my experience
it's way more simple to handle other
form data and it's the file uploads
especially multiple file uploads that
are always a bit tricky so like I said
I've done this and node one other time
but using Moltar and instead of
formidable and then I've done it in PHP
which obviously we're not going to do in
PHP for this project
so this is a bit new for me
okay our idea is upload and I do have I
have the code from my other project so
the last time I did this I actually did
use Ajax so I don't think I'm gonna use
Ajax this time obviously
so let me so as I said earlier I don't
really want to bring over my previous
code onto the screen where you all can
see just just in case I have some stuff
in there that I should not show because
it was for a client I have no idea if
there would be okay with me showing the
code anyway so that's what I'm doing
right now I'm just kind of looking at
that code alright so I can see okay I
did do one thing that I did do before
that I'm not doing now and I'm not sure
if it's needed or not is I use name
upload and then I put this in brackets
so and now that I see that I know that
at some point I did try this and it was
needed I know for sure I needed to do
this when I try to do it with PHP not
exactly sure that I need it with this
we'll see
okay it looks like I do have a file that
I'm pretty sure I could bring this over
and show you also let me show you all
what I did just to give you an idea of
like what what at least worked not sure
if it's the best okay so this takes form
data both text inputs and multi-part
upload and then it submits it so yeah so
this is Jake it's using jQuery so when
you click the submit button it goes
through and it grabs the values which in
our case our values are already stored
in state so we won't have to actually go
and select the the elements themselves
we already have all that so that'll be
easy okay I do have a toggle so
depending on what's checked this this
data gets sent to a different email
address okay and here's what I did with
the form data so this is what I'm I'm
actually most interested in so I created
a new form data object and then I
appended all the fields
and then I loop through the files and I
appended that as well and then I use
Ajax to do a post request right here to
send a post to our upload
okay so you can see these are the steps
we're not obviously not going to use
jQuery to do this but these are the
basic steps that we need to follow
oh okay I just
so John 100 says I've been saying I have
been poned but the site is have I been
poned that's probably why I kept typing
it wrong
have I been phone so I was trying to
type in I think I was trying time and I
have been phone so thank you for that so
sorry for the for the mistake so have I
been poned that makes more sense
alright so I'm gonna pull this over and
just as a reference for the steps that I
need to take so we need the button and
where's our button our submit button
here we go so here's our button so we
need to have a non clay
and
hello form data so appears somewhere
no probably gonna get yeah I don't know
that we need to pass it anything
okay so within this
okay so from what I understand basically
so we're not gonna use the submit button
in a normal way so like we didn't wrap
this in a form element and the normal
thing would be like that you you have a
submit button in your form element it
just automatically sends the form data
but normally the behavior would be that
you would have a page refresh so at
least one of the ways to handle that
when you don't want a page refresh to
happen which we don't in this case is
that you just create your form data
object with JavaScript and that's what
happens when you click the button I'm
pretty sure there are other ways to go
about this and maybe this isn't the best
way but it is the way that I have used
in the past so it's a good place to at
least start from to see if we can get it
working and then we can always refactor
if we figure out that this is not the
best way to do it
so let's um
[Music]
can you check out of state let me I
forget how our state ends up looking
area
there we go okay so you just stayed
you should be able to do
okay all right so I see Kevin this yet
this is exactly what I'm thinking right
now Kevin says you can pass a form
element to the constructor of form data
and it will be populated with the forms
current keys and values okay yeah that's
what I'm trying to do basically I just
want the the keys and values to be in
the form data object so what I was what
I was thinking of doing was I was just
going to map over all those and then
append them so is there then a better
way to do that
okay
all right so so I was looking up some
things on the other screen so you're
saying basically I need to use a
constructor oh but you would need a form
element you can map over them but you
need object dot entries okay so I was
reading that out from from the live chat
okay
okay so basically Kevin is saying in the
live chat here that I was trying to use
map which is not the right thing to use
here because we use map with arrays and
state is an object so it should not be
zoom at so any just I'm so used to using
Matt because normally well at least in
our last project we dealt with JSON all
the time and use map with it okay I got
a link
alright so John has sent a link in the
live chat for using form data from NBN
so that's probably that was probably a
decent idea here to look to check out
form data before let me pull this over
on this screen it okay so basically it
so we're all on the same page that the
what we're trying to do right now is get
all the key value pairs that are in
state that's all the information that's
it's in the inputs we're trying to move
that into our new form data object that
we've we've created so we're basically
here at this point it's empty right and
then what I was going to do was loop
over everything and then just append but
this is what we want to do
well not exactly this so because this is
still assuming that we wrapped it in a
form I guess we can't we could write
there's no reason why we know I don't
want to because I'd rather get it from I
think I would rather just get everything
from the state
I'm not sure it is there what do you
think is there any value and using kind
of the more traditional form elements
and then just preventing default on when
we click on the submit button and then
doing what we want I mean I guess that
would give us everything that we needed
all the values we needed and technique
like those values would all be exactly
the same as what's in state because
that's where the the values are coming
from
aha John said I went to the wrong page
alright let me go back form data values
okay I'm not
it looks like values are this would tell
me what all the values are from the form
data object but I guess what I want to
do is get stuff into the object first
okay Kevin has put some code in
okay I see Kevin Kevin stuff let me copy
this over so everybody can see this I'll
just add this down here okay so this is
what Kevin has pasted or typed in the
live chat so basically she's just a
okay
so we can do this but I'm I guess I'm
still now that I I saw that
I'm still wondering are we are we trying
to do in JavaScript something that the
form element already does for us should
we just use that is would I mean is
there any reason why we shouldn't just
use that so you know again like
basically you know this and then
creating our form data objects with
what's already in this this form
which is fine I'm fine doing it either
way I'm just kind of wondering what the
is there a best way in this situation
just send me a lot to wrap from yeah
okay so John says maybe wrap it in a
form seems easier okay and then Kevin
adds the the code would just be
appending the key value pairs so like
that
okay so Umberto is saying if you are not
going to have a way to handle an actual
post with postbag then do not rely on
client-side JavaScript to perform
prevent default okay so this is a reason
against using the form elements to just
wrap everything in the form tags okay
all right so I mean that's what I was
looking for basically is if we could
think of any reason why we should not
use one or the other so let's let's go
with this then
okay so within this let's pop this in
first
all right so Kevin let me look at this
so I'm actually not
I actually don't really understand this
part and what's going on here so I'm
assuming that this was necessary to be
able to use map on the state because
originally you say we can't use map on
the state because it's an object so if
you if you can if you'd like to please
let me know like just a brief
explanation of what's going on here and
then I'll I can read that out for
everybody cuz maybe you all get what's
going on here but I'm slightly lost at
least this part so I can explain the
rest which is basically we're gonna
iterate over everything and state which
are all our key value pairs for all our
form inputs and then we're gonna add it
to this form data object and then the
form data object is what we're actually
going to pass over to our server
J s and then it's going to be handled
here within this okay so everything in
here is where we're gonna actually do
what we need to do with that data
okay cool so I have an explanation now
Rudd rivering Shu says the object dot
entries method returns an array of a
given object's own innumerable property
key value pairs in the same order as
that provided by a for in loop okay so
basically it's doing we could have done
the same thing by using a loop but
that's just a much shorter way of doing
it am i understanding that correctly
Jacobi says it almost seems like you
don't have to use the map function yeah
that's a good point so yes so if this is
already going to go over everything do
we do we need the map
okay so patrick said it's it's a second
array of key value pairs that that line
is d structuring those back into key
value okay
all right I'm starting to get it
starting to get it a bit more Patrick's
is a two dimensional so
okay cool so rude rude rang Xiu is as
put the link in the live chat for the
NBN article on it so I'm gonna just save
that and check it out I'm gonna check it
out later on and just you can see so
basically if you look up global why is
this going off of my screen
that's odd anyway global object object
entries if you search that on Indiana
it'll probably come up okay all right so
Patrick is put in let me paste this over
so in the live chat Patrick just put in
so it ends up being like this okay which
this makes more sense now that this
basically allows the map to work because
now we are dealing with an array
okay so John hundred says speaking of
since this is a teaching video you might
want to edit the soundtrack for the
right website so it's a have I been
phone maybe we can put out a cliff notes
version of all these live chats yeah
that's yeah I actually since these are
all done live like I never go back in
and edit mostly because so like YouTube
just automatically post them so you
can't edit a YouTube video I'd have to
take the video down and then upload an
entirely different video so that's why I
don't do that it's possible that I could
set it so that YouTube wouldn't
automatically do it and instead I would
record it at the same time that I'm
streaming on my local machine then I
could make edits and then upload but I
don't have the time or the skill to do
that so for better or for worse these
remain unedited but I'm definitely
interested in the idea of a Cliff's
Notes version of all these these chats
alright so let's let's just try it let's
see okay now I want to
so we need to send a post Oh actually we
need to we need to handle that those
uploads so base if you remember in our
law to show you in states I believe well
actually let me check I was thinking
that in state like basically we're just
gonna have the names of the files
correct
I thought that's what how we had it I'm
pretty sure that's how we had it so
obviously like we need more than just
the names to sin
trying to find how I handled these
uploads before now I can't find it
I had the screen up
I'm just gonna start closing some
windows here because I can't find
anything at this way
there we go that's what I was looking
for just looking on the wrong screen so
that's a okay
[Music]
let's go
we need to append the files so if we
grab wood I think we just name that
upload so is there's got to be is there
like a better react way to get the value
[Music]
of an element other than document dot
get element by ID
he said upload upload upload okay
use ref okay
okay so I can use ref I remember trying
to use ref at some point within the last
six months and not getting it to work so
I'm gonna look up in the docs how to use
wrath
so here's wrath many focused readers
okay Kevin says you can use react Tom
define node react element
so which way is between the two waves
between ref and using react don't find
note which way is the better one
oh man I kept thinking like you know
what my timer hasn't gone off for a
while and evidently I had never reset it
after the break so yeah it's definitely
been enough time let me do a short break
and go back to the live set I'm sorry I
ignored you all for so long and then
we'll come back we'll get this to the
point where we can at least give it a
shot of testing it out and and then
we'll then we'll end
so this will be definitely keep this
short since we're getting towards the
end anyway
okay so Barack says Jesse thank you for
doing this you're welcome
I he says I've watched the first four
videos and this is the first live
session how many days do you expect this
project to be actually I got some
information today from one of my
co-workers that we might be changing
more about this than I thought so I'm
not really sure I can give a good
estimate right now because if there are
going to be changes then it might be
bigger a bigger project than we thought
and then also if they're going to be
changes I might have to wait and have
things reviewed before I can actually
put the changes in so I mean nothing
like code wise but just the text that's
going to appear on there might have to
be reviewed by multiple people before
it's approved to be on here so that
could lengthen things so I would I would
say like I mean what we're on day 11 I
mean I kind of think we could have this
usable by day like 20 this is probably
the biggest thing that we're working on
now everything after this is going to be
pretty easy we'll have to take some time
to set up a server but that shouldn't
take too long yeah so I'm gonna guess
maybe around 20 days if everything goes
well and there's not a lot of changes if
there's more changes more than that kind
of didn't think this would take that
long but I also thought that we would
basically be copying over all the stuff
and not changing much so we'll see we'll
see how it goes I really hope I don't
have to like stop and go to a different
project and then come back that would
just mess up the continuity of the
streams but if I'm waiting on things you
know texts to get reviewed I can't
really do anything about that
Alberto says hello I'm from Cuba I'm
also learning react and I like your
videos a lot I could contribute with
your project by adding progressive web
app capability let me know if you're
interested to coordinate yeah actually
that's that sounds really good so yeah
Albert so yeah let me know I mean you
could I mean certainly it's on github
you could do a pull request if you'd
like or if you need to like talk talk
about things with me to get it to a
better place like let me know because
I'm definitely interested I'm interested
in that I appreciate you offering to
help with that
huh John asked when I was talking
earlier about having passwords to
everything I mentioned I don't like my
kids on my computer he said you don't
have your own desktop login and your
kids and other would save you a lot of
grief yeah on my um on my macbook my
kids don't have a login it's just me and
my wife so I I pretty much never want
them on the MacBook at all I do have a
Chromebook that they I'm surprised at
how durable it is like my kids destroy
it they spill things on it they drop it
they take it like everywhere they take
it outside and just lay it on the ground
and the grass and stuff it's crazy and
it still works so I probably should make
an account for them they usually just
use my wife's login but that's a good
idea I haven't really had to worry about
it until now because they haven't really
used computers that much until kind of
recently so I'm gonna have to think
about setting things up in a better way
Bryan says use one password and generate
unique passwords for each site actually
I use I use LastPass so I do have unique
passwords for my sites
okay all right so I did say this was
gonna spin any short break and I am
gonna go back to this so I'm gonna be
true to my word there and I'll come back
and finish with a live chat as soon as
we get this working I guess I mean I'd
be okay even if it like as long as
something happens even if like it it
fails I just wanted to do something okay
so what were we oh we were doing this
okay so the the last thing we were
talking about was they're using refs
okay so kevin says ref sounds like the
way to go on this so we'll go with that
also Kevin says since we are not
returning anything from map you may want
to change it to four each or to a four
loop okay
[Music]
I guess we can change that
all right so we're talking about this
part here and replacing it with this for
loop like this correct
alright and for this part we're gonna
basically try to do this but using refs
because that that seems like the way to
go so as I said I have never
successfully used refs so I need to take
a second here and check out how to use
it
oh man I totally forgot I've had a fan
on the whole time it can you guys hear
that or can you all hear that is it
annoying the fan
okay cool it doesn't seem like anyone is
the faith it is on the lowest setting so
it was just really hot in here today so
normally I don't run run the fan when
I'm streaming
okay
okay
so on our on our input
okay and then now we can access this
this upload input okay
okay so this will select that and then
within our upload input we need to
get the data and append that to our form
data objects
so we need files
oh wait Patrick says refs don't work
with functional components this is not
yeah this this particular component
right is not okay good for a second I'll
say all admit we gotta change it again
okay but that is good to know so refs do
not work with functional components so
just FYI okay so we need to get our
files and we need to append that
so how's the files do you get an array
of files or do this give it an object I
can't remember what we're gonna get
actually let's just I want to see what
we're doing
I wonder if this will even run hey oh
that's not now which one do I want to
see for now
okay so for now I'm just using it at the
local hose 3000 because I don't have to
build things over again so let's throw
in some files and I just put in some
stuff here and then submit
[Music]
should console oh yes awesome alright so
here's what we have so we have in fact
successfully selected our upload field
or upload input and then we are getting
the file so here's a file list so we did
up one two three yeah so we uploaded
four files we see all four files here
awesome awesome
[Music]
cool so that's what we needed that's
what we want to do so we just need to
append these
so let's see how did I do this before
all right so we need to wait actually I
wanted to see that these were okay
living objects
all right so since it's an object we do
not want to use map correct
so I guess we could do a four of again
and we want
really we want to pen the whole thing
and
okay Alberto says how can I get in
contact with you if I'm on all like all
the different social media things so if
you're on Twitter you can direct message
me on Twitter or whatever whatever
social media that your do you use most
often you can just you can find the
links to all my social media stuff on my
personal YouTube channel and the link to
that channel is in the description
otherwise you could email me too you
could use just Jessie why go at
gmail.com I'll type that in the live
chat we
yeah so whichever ways most comfortable
for you
okay so uh Kevin I'm seeing Kevin
offered some alternatives to this so
Kevin just will this then work or if
this works I'll probably just keep it
like this just for the sake of time at
this point but if if you're saying that
this won't work and I need to use one of
the alternatives then that's cool I'll
replace it
all right so now that we're a pending
that the next thing to do is would be to
actually post the data so what I want to
do is use fetch
so
let's show us in the studio with fish
[Music]
it's a 10-point it's just
yeah
and then
[Music]
first
my head yesterday
to even need headers maybe not trying to
look on my other screen I have what I
had used for when I was doing this with
Ajax so I'm just trying to translate
that into my fetch to make sure that I'm
doing the same thing okay I don't need
that it's it's slightly different how
you put things links in with fetch
[Music]
hello says I give up it so hard no don't
give up yet we're almost there
alright fool as a body what if I can get
away with this and just putting just
putting data in the body
maybe that's all I need I had a lot more
to my Ajax call but I just kind of want
to see if this works
looks like the minimum that we would
need to make this work
I don't really want to do anything with
the response just yet I guess
all right so at least now at this point
it would go here now let's make sure
we're doing what we need to over here
okay the only thing I'm not I'm not sure
about this last part why are we I'm not
sure what's going on here
and I don't know where my documentation
is at for formidable
I can't remember we got this from from a
tutorial didn't we yeah we did
yeah I'm not really sure why we're
sending this and there's not there's
really no explanation given in the in
the tutorial
so I'm going through the on my other
screen I'm just scrolling through the
documentation and formidable
alright let's just get rid of that for
now since I really not sure about it
okay so at least this should give us a
console.log all right let's try it out
like this
see
um we'll build it let's stop the server
let's build it
okay
all right now
it's good
we get some errors
okay check this we got nothing in here
expected to see something
all right so we had so nothing have
nothing is probably the worst thing that
could happen I would have rather had an
error message
all right let's see
okay the good thing is since since I
just changed this I don't need to build
again I can what did I do with my
terminal I put on my other screen okay
you should be able to just close this
and then reopen it
okay actually
okay we got an error
so here's our error those slip those
uploads can I should reset
all right cool and we got our message
here awesome unless I wanted at least an
error message
not really sure what to make out of this
but at least I got something
okay
Joseph said no need for the get method
also in the server jazz the get method
was in here from the this as little as
came from the create react app
documentation so I think I need this to
serve the the site itself
I mean we were those you see those areas
we were getting
all right so I
guessing
I was trying to figure out where to look
first
okay these are conflicting
all right
I'll show this
oh this is who we get
okay cool got some different error best
progress event status
I don't have a file uploads okay so
we're just expected at project resource
center uploads okay
alright now let's share it again
haha look at that look at that alright
take this out can everyone see that the
files have been uploaded yes alright
so we did it we got files all right I'm
not saying that this is completely like
a hundred percent the way we want it to
be in the final version but like we have
no error handling so but basically it's
doing what we wanted it to do the files
are in there and so basically our errors
were our first error was pretty much we
were just trying to do two different
things that were conflicting here is
basically I just copied this over from a
tutorial and I'm pretty sure they were
trying to do something that I was not
trying to do so this was what was better
to put in here then we got a second
error simply because I was telling it to
put the files and the uploads directory
and I didn't create an uploads directory
so I just had to create that directory
so just for future reference if you're
trying to do something like that watch
out for for those errors probably the
first error you might not get but this I
can imagine that this might be like a
common thing that gets overlooked
awesome okay cool
I thought I just I knew we were close so
this stream has gone on longer than a
normal stream but I just we were so
close I just didn't want to stop until
we got it so really cool so basically we
you know we've got the uploads coming in
and now they're going into this folder
which is great which means so unlike I
think I explained in a previous stream
the problems I was having with the
current uploads in that the files are
being uploaded but they're not being
stored anywhere instead they're being
sent to our project management system
and the issue sometimes is that the
files don't get sent and I know they're
supposed to be files because the file
names are sent but the files themselves
don't get sent so I'm losing the files I
have no backup of those files and what
happens if somebody from my department
has to call whoever it made that
submission and ask them to resend or
just email them the files or something
that's not really ideal so this what
this allows us to do is we have a backup
of the files we can choose now to try to
send the files to the API through the
API directly to our project management
system which will probably still do but
as a backup we can also send the URL to
access these files if we wanted to so
I'm not exactly sure how I want to do it
but the bottom line is we have a backup
now so we should not lose files anymore
would never want to leave it like this
right now I'm doing no checking to see
if somebody's trying to upload a
malicious file or anything so definitely
don't want to leave it like this but you
can see that it works everything else
basically is just checking things out
before we do this step of actually
saving the file so now on to questions
[Music]
yes I see a couple a couple of good
suggestions so Joseph says now get the
return from the response and print a
message accordingly yeah so we want to
do something right to let the user know
that it worked right I'm like I'm not
gonna do anything else for this stream
since I already applaud you all for
suffering through all of that until it
works so 25 of you it looks like made it
all the way through to the end so
hopefully getting it to work in the end
was satisfying enough that it was worth
sticking around it definitely was for me
I feel so happy that we get that to work
so yeah definitely wanted to have a
response Kevin says are you gonna do a
thank-you page or show a modal F
reformist unsuccessfully yeah I think
probably a modal yeah I think currently
I show a modal so I'll probably just
keep it like that Patrick says you may
want to think about making uniquely
named folders under the uploads folder
to prevent naming collisions yeah that's
a good idea
I think what I had done previously is
when I done something like this before
I actually used like I got the date and
I appended that to the file name so that
every file name was unique and then that
made sure because the only thing I'm
thinking is can I even make folders
because it's not I may have to do
something else or maybe get another
package to be able to let let me make
folders automatically because it it
wouldn't let it didn't find the upload
folder maybe it's already built in but I
just need to do something else to have
it make the folder first so either way
I'm fine with it either having a folder
that's a different name for the folder
like let's say each folder has a date on
it and then the files go in there or
actually changing the file names
then as long as I keep track of what I
changed the filenames to which shouldn't
really be a problem then I can always go
back and access those if I need to so
yeah but anyway good suggestion okay
yeah Kevin said or unique prefix yeah
yeah I can um had it and usually like
date date is pretty good I mean the odds
of somebody like what what are the odds
of like files being uploaded
simultaneously at exactly the same time
like is that is that even possible like
I don't know
so okay Kevin says FS dot make directory
or FS dot make directory sync okay cool
so there's definitely a way to do it
okay it looks like alright cool Joseph
is I said I know I said I wasn't gonna
do anything else but says also some
response like this so let me paste this
in says this correct so what I can I
have all these at the same time or these
gonna conflict
you can tell I'm definitely a noob when
it comes to using Express in nodejs so I
like I've done it when I had to do it
and I was able to get things working
that I needed to but not really
confident enough to customize it a whole
lot it takes a lot of research for me to
do anything with this
okay I need to remove one remove the
first okay cool
let's remove the first one okay cool so
and then like so I've done if I've done
this now on the other end when I get the
response I can do something with the
response which like I said I'll probably
end up having a modal appear so I'm
definitely not gonna try to code that
right now actually I've never done a
modal with material UI before so that'll
be cool get to learn how to do modal so
maybe that'll be tomorrow we'll finish
up and give the user some feedback
okay.what bangs shoe says not semicolon
it's a chain function okay cool so I'm
gonna get rid of do you want to get rid
of that semicolon
success your status fine
okay I'm better just saying we can do it
like this lots of options so let's see
so I can combine that then and do
something like this cool all right cool
I'm going to alright at this point I'm
just gonna save everything I'm gonna
make sure let's um what do you think
this is
is this working enough that I could
actually put this merge this back in the
master at this point or should we leave
it on a separate branch and want to get
it like actually finished maybe I'll
just leave it on a separate branch for
now cuz it's not like it's really
finished finish it's you know it's we've
got the first like major step done we've
got that to work but we still need to
finish it off
so let's check it out everything that we
have here I do not want the uploads
folder actually yeah I don't really want
the uploads folder to be synced let's
put that in in our get ignored
there we go
okay just saying I could do a blank
upload folder and not the files
themselves yeah that's true I kind of
want to make it so we were saying
earlier that we could automatically make
the directory so I think I want to do
that so I want to not sink the uploads
folder but instead maybe make the floor
is there a way that I could check to see
if the folder exists and if it doesn't
exist then create the folder because I
think that would be ideal
I don't know we'll see I could always
add it in later
I guess it would be a big deal right now
to get rid of these so don't really want
to keep them there anyway let's get rid
of those and then I can take this off
for now you just comment that out for
now might put it back in all right so
now I don't know it was already in there
and I thought let me do it again
okay cool here it is
alright I'm gonna save that but like I
said I'm not gonna do anything about it
right now but so this is what I want to
check to see if this if this suggest if
not we'll make it so that's what I do
want to do at some point but not right
now cuz need to get this finished up how
about this let me just answer the
questions now and then I'll worry about
committing this so I think I've gone
over enough git commits that most but
pretty much most of you if not all of
you will have seen see me do a commit so
you know I normally do like to do it but
in this case it's been a really long
stream so I'll just do it after
alright I'm definitely gonna have to go
back over the chat to get because
there's so much good advice here that I
want to make sure I don't miss it also
after this is over I'll go back through
so at this point now I'm gonna do
question and answer if you don't really
care about question and answer and you
know you want to stop watching at this
point that's cool thank you so much for
watching I'll be back tomorrow 2:00 p.m.
Eastern Time
otherwise if you have any questions go
ahead and throw them in here I'll do my
best to get through them all probably I
don't want to take too too long so I'm
going to try to go through quickly
because this is going to end up being a
three hour long stream
all right so I'm at this point I'm just
scrolling through trying to find
questions to answer and I'm skipping
through most of the discussion and
sometimes I do read out everything if I
have time but I'm not going to at this
point
okay all right I found the point where I
left off
[Music]
okay we were talking about I had said
before I still have access to a lot of
stuff from past clients and it's just
like a weird situation so I did get some
responses here about things so it seems
like seems like at least a few of you
also have access to things like that but
Rohan had a good suggestion here so I'm
gonna really says I probably wouldn't
want to access their sites to distance
myself if they try to blame me for
something that went wrong but on the
other hand yeah some people can be dumb
yeah so yeah that's just I don't really
want to get in and access the sites
either I'm just not exactly sure what to
do because I mean what do I do at this
point you would I you have to contact
the client convince them that this is
actually something they should care
about and then make them an admin have
them delete my admin account yeah it
just seems like it would be a lot of a
lot of time and a lot of steps and
probably wouldn't be a big deal I mean
most of these sites are talking about
are like very simple WordPress sites for
small businesses so it's not like it's
going to be the end of the world if if
something ever happened to them
patrick said so patrick was going
through a bunch of passwords that that
had been stolen looking for see if his
were in there i said he searched
password and act and did find it in the
list so that's crazy i can't believe
people we use that okay so i'm actually
not seeing a ton of questions it's a lot
of a lot of the advice you you all were
giving me along the way okay so it looks
like nexi asks is he creating a website
or what so I'm assuming that that
question got answered but just in case
yeah it's it's a website so it's the
main purpose of the website is to allow
people where I work to request services
from my department through an online
form and there's going to be a few other
things they can do as well but that's
that's the big the big thing that we're
working on the thing is going to take
the most effort and time to get working
it's funny going through this live chat
now I remember like all the things that
I messed up along the way because I I
can see y'all saying like no don't do it
that way or do this
oh man John Henson says kids can be
surprising my son in the early days of
computers had magical powers of how to
get around locked shareware games at the
age of six Wow
yeah I definitely gotta get my computers
ready for my kids I have an 8 year old
so yeah I need to and like I said they
weren't really on the computer too much
except for like that we had a Chromebook
they just watch shows on it but now my
son started playing minecraft so I have
them on one of my old Windows computers
playing Minecraft so I really need to
get that locked down so you can just
play Minecraft and not potentially mess
and that's with anything else
ciao ask anyone used drag-and-drop
functionality on react app no I've never
used any drag-and-drop stuff
Patrick says Dan Abramov wrote react D&D
for that the end is react - D and D he
thinks that's the name of it so awesome
also asks anybody have experience
getting values of dynamically created
input fields and react and revering xu
says put it into an array with indices
for the new fields update the state with
a new array every time a new field is
added cool thanks for that thanks for
that answer
ok Kevin says in response to that same
question in the code that generates them
passed them and on change and then you
could just do this handle change and use
the same code for handle change that I
use that in this project so and add them
to state when you generate them
okay Wow it looks like I've gotten
through everything in the live chat so
there there's a lot of stuff in there
the majority of it was stuff we've
already gone through it was just a lot
of suggestions of what to do when we
were building this I did get something
in a language that I cannot read so let
me translate this really quick because
there is a question mark at the end so
it's a question
Google Translate is so useful okay I
think the question was something about
are there any Russians here so yeah so I
not me I'm in the United States but yeah
occasionally we do have people from
Russia in here as well so I don't know
if there's anybody in here right now but
I think that was the question is or that
was what the question was
see yeah I think it I think it was
basically just hello or they're Russians
all right so I'm to the end of the chat
I'm actually really like exhausted after
all that don't livestreams takes a lot
out of you all right so I'm going to
push this stuff up to github before I
leave today so probably within the next
half an hour it'll be on get up and that
way if anybody wants to take a look at
it you'll have it there I'm probably not
gonna do anything else to it I'm just
gonna push it as is cuz it's getting
pretty late here is about something for
me to leave work thank you all so much
yours like such a big help I know I say
that at every stream but it is true for
every stream and especially today this
was like this was a big deal this was
the one thing in this project that I was
thinking like how am I gonna do this and
and we did it so so it's awesome so
thank you and thanks everybody for
watching I will be back place at
tomorrow 2 p.m. eastern time yeah and I
have have a great day I'll see everybody
tomorrow